bonjour karine rousseau
bonjour monsieur livory bonjour à toutes
et à tous un bon jour la martinique vous
êtes secrétaire territorial des
républicains quelle analyse faites vous
de la première vague de 428 candidat
investi par la république en marche des
manuels mâcon et bien écoutez
visiblement il y aurait 52 % de
personnes qui n'ont jamais eu de vie
politique donc ça c'est la première
chose
plus qu'une analyse je ferai des
constats et puis ce qui est intéressant
c'est quand même positif dont je n'ai de
relever oui et non oui et non on en
reparlera et puis deuxième chose 100 %
des candidats qui ont été investis et
qui sont des anciens députés sont des
socialistes
donc ça montre bien finalement que
macron est bien comme nous l'avions dit
le le digne successeur de hollande ce
qu'en dit bon sang mais c'est quand même
de son renouvellement non c'est qu'à
renouveler la classe politique
c'est un renouvellement et nous avons
aussi nous des candidats nouvellement
investi et nous allons aussi renouveler
la classe politique nous nous on suit la
preuve puisque aux républicains nous
avons aussi investi nos candidats et que
notre but pour cette troisième bataille
ce troisième tour des élections
présidentielles qui finalement est la
mère des batailles
notre but c'est de gagner la majorité au
parlement et nous offrons un programme
aux martiniquais ou martiniquaise une
majorité pour la france et pour la
martinique avec nos candidats investis
par les républicains alors
certaines circonscriptions veste
toujours sur ce qui se passait dans dans
avec un marché lire à la république en
marche certaines circonscriptions en
france ont été laissés libres notamment
celles de députés aient l'air si un
appel du pied claf emmanuel macron que
fait manuel macron public hein je pense
qu'aujourd'hui
l'appel du pied qu'il a essayé de tenter
effectivement est restée sans réponse
puisque vous savez qu aucun républicain
aujourd'hui n'a rejoint en marche
donc nous restons bien soudée dans notre
famille politique ne se ce n'est pas de
la résistance c'est tout simplement de
la conviction des convictions que nous
avons emmanuel macron a fait une
campagne dans l'ambiguïté c'est un
équilibriste un pas en avant un pas en
arrière pas à droite un pas à gauche
nous nous faisons une campagne
aujourd'hui dans la clarté pour offrir
au martini quasi aux martiniquais à
l'assemblée nationale une majorité de la
droite et du centre
vous savez il a été un équilibriste un
pas à droite à gauche sur plusieurs
sujets sur les 35 heures sur l'impôt sur
la fortune sur un certain nombre de
sujets et nous nous faisons une campagne
dans la clarté puisque nous proposons un
contrat d'alternance aux martiniquais 0
martinique et à l'assemblée nationale
avec nos candidats états unis sauf s'il
le dit le premier ministre d'emmanuel
macron sort de vos rangs vous faites
quoi
ça ne sera pas le cas donc je ne suis
pas inquiète donc vous pouvez passer à
la question suivante une majorité donc
vous chercher absolument à a gagné ces
élections il ya aussi une cohabitation
si ça alors nous cherchons et évidemment
nous
nous gagnerons ces élections à
l'assemblée nationale et surtout nous
portons en projet un projet autour de
trois piliers qui sont pour nous
essentiel l'école qui doit redevenir ce
qu'elle était c'est à dire permettre à
chacun d'acquérir les fondamentaux
aucun jeune ne doit sortir sans
qualification de l'école et puis l'école
où on doit retrouver le mérite la
méritocratie l'entreprise évidemment
puisque ce que nous proposons c'est de
diminuer les charges sociales de façon
très importante pour les entreprises
notamment en martinique
nous savons que notre tissu est composé
à 98% de petites entreprises pour ces
petites entreprises là nous avons des
mesures très précises et qui vont leur
permettre de se libérer de souffler un
peu un podium qui a changé le et enfin
la famille la famille parce que c'est
vrai que les familles ont été abandonnés
nous proposons par exemple de remettre
en place l'universalité des allocations
familiales parce que vous savez
qu'aujourd'hui certaines familles n'ont
plus les allocations familiales donc
redonner du pouvoir d'achat aux familles
et puis la laïcité bien sûr je vous
disais qu'il ya changé un programme qui
a changé ce n'est plus celui de françois
fillon que vous avez des temps défendu
pendant la campagne présidentielle
écoutez francesca lebon celui qui allait
glisser la marque la presse françois
fillon aux frais un programme du
changement un programme donc le match
alors je n'en mange pas si si tout à
fait un programme qui finalement je
voulais changer le logiciel de la france
maintenant aujourd'hui le changement
n'ont absolument pas nous nous
continuons c'est ce que je vais vous
dire dans cette logique de changement et
de changement de logiciel pour la france
et pour la martinique
aujourd'hui nous savons que ce qui a
péché entre guillemets dans notre
candidature ça a été les affaires qui
ont pesé sur notre candidate se dit mais
évidemment nous continuons à défendre ce
changement de logiciel qu'il faut pour
la france
la première chose importante c'est de
redonner du pouvoir d'achat
la martiniquaise et aux martiniquais
exit en existe deux points de tva vous
n'en parlez plus alors là effectivement
il n'y aura pas d'augmentation de la tva
ni de la csg puisque c'est ce que
propose monsieur macro je vous précise
que monsieur macron sera comme monsieur
hollande le candidat du matraquage
fiscal de 2012 à 2017 50 milliards
d'impôts et de charges en plus ont été
payés par les français ne risque pas de
rendre difficile et je la campagne des
législatives absolument pas puisque nous
avons un programme avec en contrat
d'alternance que je vais présenter
pendant un mois avec les autres
candidats des républicains mais pour
revenir sur monsieur vaincrons il
propose d'augmenter de 1,7 pour cent la
cotisation sociale généralisée ce qui
pèsera sur les fonctionnaires les
retraités certainement les salariés donc
nous ne voulons pas de cette
augmentation d'impôts nous effectivement
n'augmenteront pas la tva et surtout
nous proposons de diminuer de 10 %
l'impôt sur le revenu de chaque français
est d'augmenter les petites pensions de
retraites et les pensions de réversion
donc vraiment nous avons un programme
pour le pouvoir d'achat des français
très important comment se passe on va
parler des législatives il nous reste à
peine 5 minutes comment se passe le
rassemblement
en martinique le rassemblement au niveau
des républicains mais il se passe très
très bien nous sommes solidaires tous
derrière le candidat n'ont absolument
pas c'est une réalité
vous savez ya tout un mythe qui disait
que beaucoup de républicains seraient
partis sur la yole macro il s'est avéré
que ce n'est pas le cas parce que nous
sommes des personnes de convictions et
je vous dis que nous avons un programme
à défendre et que nous le défendrons et
que nous gagnerons la majorité pour la
france votre candidat est candidate dans
la circonscription du centre atlantique
quels seront les grands thèmes de liszt
grands thèmes que vous avez vous allez
développer localement alors premièrement
le pouvoir d'achat des martiniquaises et
des martiniquais j'en ai déjà parlé avec
les mesures que j'ai annoncée
deuxièmement libérer les entreprises des
contraintes et surtout des charges
sociales et des impôts
donc tout ce qui est défiscalisation
sera évidemment pérenniser jusqu'en haut
- 2027
nous décidons de diminuer l'impôt sur
les sociétés sur l'ensemble de la france
à 25% mais pour les entreprises
martiniquaises à 15%
car il faut vraiment relancer
l'entreprise martiniquaise et surtout
nous allons créer pour la martinique le
statut de l'entreprise franche ce qui
n'existait pas une entreprise qui sera
totalement exonérées de charges et
d'impôts pour peu qu'elle ait quelques
elle qu'elle puisse montrer qu'elle est
une entreprise en concurrence avec
d'aider d'autres entreprises qu'ils
viennent d'ailleurs que ce qui vous
empêche de collabo vit aujourd'hui avec
avec emmanuel macron bien écouter
emmanuel macron n'a pas de ligne
politique claire
emmanuel macron encore une fois est le
candidat de l' ambiguïté nous nous
sommes les candidats de la clarté de la
droite et du centre et nous avons un
programme clair et transparent pour les
français est vraiment ce que nous
proposons aujourd'hui aux martiniquais
c'est un contrat d'alternance un contrat
pour protéger les français
un contrat d'équité pour que l'égalité
des chances soient enfin une réalité
surtout pour nous en martinique un
contrat pour le plus
l'emploi et le pouvoir d'achat des
martiniquaises et des martiniquais
vous avez déjà désigné votre supplions
oui mon suppléant est jonathan tabarki à
29 ans qui est un gros mornais je dirais
un jeune homme de conviction un jeune
homme qui a la valeur comme moi du
travail et qui aujourd'hui est sur le
terrain partout et voilà nous formons
une belle équipe
comment s'est fait le choix pourquoi et
bien écoutez moi je souhaitais que mon
suppléant soit quelqu'un d'abord de
conviction et je crois que c'est
quelqu'un qui a des convictions
politiques en créant lui qui fait de la
politique depuis très longtemps qu'ils
envient travailler pour son pays et qui
est un jeune courageux et bosseur et ce
qui je crois que c'est une valeur pour
moi et surtout c'est quelqu'un de très
honnête en politique l'honnêteté je
crois que c'est une valeur importante
parce que qui se perd donc vous
inscrivez si je comprends bien près de
cet entretien dans une opposition
systématique à emmanuel macron ou une
position de petit constructive il y a
toujours une opposition à apporter mais
l'opposition ne peut pas évidemment être
systématique bien sûr que nous nous nous
inscrivons dans une opposition
constructive mais surtout nous ne
lésineront pas sur les moyens de faire
re décoller la martinique est ni
économiquement et je vous parle en
particulier de pouvoir d'achat des
martiniquais et de nos entreprises qui
ont trop de contraintes trop de normes
et surtout qu'ils payent trop d'impôts
aujourd'hui en particulier dans certains
secteurs comme le tourisme
puis il y a une chose importante aussi
c'est que nous voulons libérer la
martinique de certaines normes
européennes qui se superposent aux
normes finalement que nous avons et qui
font qu'aujourd'hui nous avons trop de
contraintes je parle en particulier dans
certains secteurs comme l'agriculture la
pêche ou nous voulons vraiment aller
négocier à bruxelles
la sortie de ces normes européennes qui
nous qui nous empêchent d'avancer encore
vous ne seriez pas au second tour vous
allez appeler à voter fabrice
non philippe edmond-mariette g serait au
second tour donc vous pouvez passer à la
prochaine question car elle nous sort je
vous remercie
merci beaucoup et merci à tous et bonne
journée puis suivez notre programme sur
notre page facebook
gros boulot à les consommer aussi
passionné sauna journée sur notre
antenne